thoughts on crime consequences i mean
what
what does that even mean right um so
there's an alternate universe on some
uh coverage
the white house facing heavy criticism
after press secretary jensachi appeared
to laugh off concerns over rising crime
the head of the largest police union in
the country calling out the
administration saying this i think it's
wrong very wrong for miss sake to
suggest that violent crime in our
country is of no concern or just to
laugh it off she may feel safe in the
white house one of the most protected
buildings in the united states but not
everyone feels safe in their workplace
and a new poll putting americans at odds
with the white house's assessment voters
saying they're frustrated with how the
president has responded to a spike in
violence sixty-four percent disapprove
of how biden is tackling crime overall
and now some businesses feel forced to
take matters into their own hands a
california jewelry store owner
frustrated with local officials after
fending off would be robbers by himself
nobody's doing anything even
even just now
i i think you know they got all the
surveillance videos then
they've been working on them but haven't
heard anything they're there nothing
happens i really wanted to reach out to
those
lawmakers to do something but nothing
happened nothing happened
jesse in the reuters poll crime is in
the top five concern of all americans
actually eclipsing covid
yeah but the democrats are like we're
gonna save your life from kovid but
you're on your own with crime what sense
does that make right now joe's just
trying to throw cash at the situation to
get out of this you know those guys in
the movies that just take a lot of cash
and just throw it in your face and say
here shut up go buy yourself a fleet of
new squad cars and that's what the
democrats do though afghanistan the
public education system war on poverty
here's a trillion dollars now stop
complaining we care because we're
spending a lot of money the dem the
democrats say the republicans don't care
as much as we do we just want you to
take the money and shut the heck up
right now you could buy every single
officer in the country x-ray vision a
drug sniffing dog and have them walk
around with a stack of cash just bribe
informants and it wouldn't do a damn
thing because the da's just gonna let
guys walk the dumb laws are just gonna
let people walk so until you fix that
throwing cash around is not a strategy i
think the calculation for democrats is
this they actually think that black
voters won't vote for them if they are
tough on crime like black mothers and
fathers like the gun play they like the
stick ups in their neighborhood no one
likes that no one wants that they want
people to be tough on crime but they
also want people to be fair why can't
democrats strike that balance and why
are they treating black neighborhoods
different than white neighborhoods
democrats wouldn't tolerate this kind of
violence in their neighborhood that's
really disgusting on covid
you can't have any risk on kovit you
have to wear a face shield you have to
stay home for days you have to keep your
kids home but let's roll the dice on
crime right let's take an ex-con that's
deranged in the head and he shoots up a
gas station but let's let him out with
no bail and just run the risk of doing
it all over again it doesn't make any
sense does it it doesn't it does not it
does as it says in your as it says in
your promo you know common sense
i felt bad for the guy that
protected himself because he's saying
and they still even after all of this
it's on video he protected his store and
himself and he said still feels like
nobody cares nobody does care uh well
let me let me say they don't care until
it affects them um nearly all the
victims
of violent crime are black right and
they would be alive right now if it
wasn't for the manipulation of the
police narratives by the media and the
activists right so what happened was
just to show you how disconnected the
media is from the real world in the days
after these multiple cop killings and
shootings what did cnn run a special
that highlighted police misconduct this
is like right around when the funerals
are happening and what they did is a
typical kind of like clip job special
where they take isolated incidents put
them together no stats and just make it
out as misconduct against blacks it's
like the greatest hits for people who
hate the police and they were the
argument was cops should not be pulling
over people if they're armed which
obviously would not affect cnn at all
because it's not like that's their
problem everybody who works there is
protected with armed security so if you
actually they're so if you actually knew
a police officer most of us do all of us
do you would not have fallen for this
anti-police narrative and i do think the
white-collar elitism that you find in
the media has separated those people
from knowing anybody from plumbers to
cops not understanding their problems
the essential truth is the people
either in this denial or this delusion
don't live where the crime is and their
false reporting that it was hunting
season on blacks by cops made it worse
in the in the areas where there is black
on black crime we have there's a study
now that showed that democrats believe
that cops killed a thousand black
black people when it was unarmed maybe
between eleven to two dozen i think
averaging over the year but that's
because of the way it was reported
roughly fifty percent of the homicides
are done by 17 to 15 of the population
the cops need to focus on that area but
now they can't right they can't focus on
that area which created more black on
black crime because they're not their
policing so who caused all this death
who caused the ferguson effect or the
george floyd effect now who caused that
who caused the cops to retreat from the
areas where they were needed most it was
the media it was black lives matter it
was the activists and now you have
thousands of black people who are dead
that shouldn't be dead and it's on their
doorstep and interesting they that when
you mentioned the police officers
that we had a young woman on from the
police department in san francisco she'd
been there i think 25 years she decided
to leave one of her big complaints when
she left is that the
d.a out there chesa boudin has basically
that somebody in his office is
withholding evidence about an
officer-involved situation officer
stangle's case and they're calling for
the complete misconduct by the d.a
because they're not protecting the
police officer well you know there's no
surprise when you've got rogue
prosecutors who are funded by george
soros their whole mission is to release
the criminals they have no interest in
protecting the victims and if the if the
victim happens to be a police officer
then it's an even worse situation you
know just let this guy ignore everything
that has to do with it
with his situation but i think what's
amazing about jen
sacking the democrats is her response to
that initial you know these people are
in an alternate universe
she says that there was 350 million
dollars in the american rescue plan and
and the
washington post gave it three pinocchios
when she said that money could have gone
to police and not one republican voted
for it here's your response to that your
response to that is that money wasn't
earmarked for police it could have been
used for any one of a number of things
and police were not specifically
mandated to receive that money that's
number one number two and number two
what we've got now is we've got uh
merrick garland is coming to new york
city i understand tomorrow along with
the governor hocal and the president and
they're all going to come in and say
we're going to take care of you all
we're going to protect you all nonsense
if you remember merrick garland is the
guy who came out and said yeah those
parents are domestic terrorists here fbi
i'm going to sick you after those
domestic terrorist parents then you've
got the hoco who says yeah to the ada to
the d.a bragg the new prosecutor is not
going to be tough on crime she says yeah
you've got to be tough on crime but then
she goes wink wink to her legislative
friends in albany no we're not going to
change any of the bail laws so we're
going to let them out loose so the
democrats want them out that's part of
their agenda if they're coming tomorrow
geraldo they will see that
the second funeral for the
nypd officer he will be laid to rest
tomorrow and that funeral will happen uh
around i think it starts at 10 a.m and
then thursday the president is coming
here i guess he's one he says he wants
to deal with gun issues uh he'll be in a
in an appearance with eric adams who's
the new mayor do you think that eric
adams will say something to him about
the
progressive prosecutors i know that uh
eric adams likes joe biden i think that
eric adams is pleased that the president
is coming here as a as i am i i give
them uh the benefit of the doubt i think
that uh his coming here is a good signal
they're also going to a crime-riddled
neighborhood in queens i believe uh so i
i think that's good i think that the
deaths of these two officers maura and
rivera uh will be a seminal moment
historically uh i think that this is
where the defund the police movement
died this is where cops were again the
virtuous friend of the family and i i am
deeply moved by uh their their families
and how they have spoken uh i'm proud of
the city i'm proud of them and i think
that they really have uh changed things
i just want to say one thing about the
self-defense uh shopkeepers
when i was a young reporter in this town
it was very common in bodegas in the
neighborhoods i knew best where there a
guy would be hired he'd be behind the
counter or in the back room he'd have a
shotgun and if something like this came
in he would come and fire off and above
the heads uh but the this kind of
nonsense would not happen even in the
city when it was really riddled with
crime when we were over 2 000 homicides
a year
i want also to remember what i've said
about technology i think the way to beat
this creepy trend is technology this
should be the explosive dies that they
have in money in the banks every one of
these jewelry stores should be uh the
the counter should be
wired so that they have this exploding
thing sirens should go off we can't let
them come in and fill their bags and
leave because success just breeds more
you're right and we had these videos and
it was it was like god sending us
evidence when it happened but now we've
got prosecutors who won't even prosecute
the case they won't even look at the
videos well i think that
i would like very much for the president
of the united states to say something
look at the video out of out of
character say something about
you know
if someone comes and uses a gun in a
robbery that person is going to jail for
the robbery and the gun
that's it that would be getting that
would be changing the policy which is
what they've said they haven't done it
if they do okay we'll welcome it hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else